hey what's up guys my name is the Cherno
and welcome to episode 22 of network
chat programming so last time of course
we went ahead and created this client
window so that we differentiate client
from client window kind of the same way
that we differentiate server main from
server okay just so that we can uh we
can see what's happening a bit more
clear and if we want to handle client
stuff we know that it's gonna be over
here and you can see it's nice and
simple right 78 lines of code that is
all that our client does as far as the
network side of things is concerned and
of course you can see that we don't need
to deal with all of this GUI code in the
way the kind of makes things really
messy so that of course was a good thing
and today we're just gonna basically
talk about how to verify if the client
does indeed established a successful
connection to the server or not okay so
just to walk you through the kind of the
flowchart of what's happening we start a
server here when we start a client and
when we try to connect to it if you go
ahead into client window you'll see that
as soon as we create a client and as
soon as because of course lot log in the
log in the Java class is what actually
creates a new instance of client we
actually tried to establish a connection
here and when that does happen we okay
so if we just can command click or
control-click if you're on Windows on
that method you can see what actually
what actually goes down here so we try
and open a new data grab socket with
course those parameters and well what
happens here is let's say let's quickly
just scroll up alright so we create a
new diagram socket here we sign it to
any kind of thing but um the idea the
idea of this is that because we're not
using TCP the we don't actually connect
to a thing when we create a new socket
we're not actually plugging it in
anywhere okay that's not how you DP
works that's our TCP works when you
create a new TCP socket
what actually happens is you literally
have to plug it in somewhere and
establish that one way well not
necessarily one way but establish that
physical connection whereas in UDP when
you create a new socket you're just
binding a port on your system being like
alright this port is what is the port
that's going to be used for any further
communication that we might want to do
here and of course the only thing that
actually establishes any kind of
connection to the server ever is of
course
the descend little method here okay
because that cracks that caress and you
pack it with the destination being the
IP and port and then it sends it okay so
our only way of seeing whether the
server actually gets whether the server
actually receives that message or
whether we are actually indeed connected
to the server the only way we will ever
ever see that is um is if we handle if
we actually write a method for is
there's nothing in the the the UDP
protocol that actually specifies that
any kind of confirmation has to be made
which is one of its charms but also of
course makes it kind of impractical or
even being practical kind of dumb for a
chat application but of course the
reason we're doing this is because we
need to UM well because this is what
we're going to be using in the game
programming series so to handle this
what we're actually gonna do is of
course what happens here the CL thing
right so we send a attempting in
connection to okay and then we send this
string connection plus name okay so
client send connection or get bytes
we've sent that now this is important
okay what we want to do is receive our
unique identify if it gets assigned to
us so I'm going to go ahead and say
private int ID okay and we'll set that
equal to negative one right now meaning
that it has not been specified and then
what we'll do over here is we will I
guess we'll try I guess we just hop over
into this receive a little method here
in client and so I've got receive
packets so string messages this now if
if so if message dot starts whether we
can give it a prefix so if I think what
was convention that we used in d7 it's
going to open up the not that one I'm
just gonna open up the server class that
we created so we had a little um let's
see did we deal with that my imagining
things
yeah we did okay so okay so we had full
slash character full slash so full slash
any character like m for example so um
c stands to connection here so we'll go
ahead and use the same one why not so if
it starts with that then clearly this
message is a connection-oriented message
in a will take
our little thing so similarly how we did
over here in client window oh sorry in
server main not server main in server
where we we went ahead and we let's see
here so we did that good how we did a
little substring thing we're gonna do
the same thing here which is um
basically take the strength tape take
this message so we'll go ahead and make
string actually ok so what's an integer
so we'll go ahead and make an integer
called ID will set that equal to message
dot substring and the begin index will
be 0 the end and the end index will be 3
and up all the way around so three and
then message dot length do we have to
minus one from that and I don't remember
no it doesn't look like it ok cool so
that that will be this of course we need
two integer dot parse int and then if we
get if we get an exception thrown from
this it means that we've not departed
the string correctly so we've got our ID
now in fact we can just set this dot ID
equal to that and then this is a kind of
our confirmation so because of that whoo
that's in the other ones that's
interesting okay so this isn't the other
one so what we're probably gonna do then
in that case is yeah that makes sense
doesn't it so I probably just put into
the wrong thing so in client window
instead of having ID here we will rather
just have ID in here and then we can
always get it using a get method
together so we'll keep ID here and then
we'll go ahead and set that as it should
be now we also probably print something
to the console here which I think
happens that if this is the other probe
this is the other thing we need to deal
with
I guess well not really deal with
because it's not a problem at all it's
just kind of like working out how we
want to do things so I'm just grab some
water cuz it's 40 degrees 40 degrees
Celsius here right now a lot in my room
but outside so the thing that we have to
figure out it because we got interface
and kind of back-end we we don't have
like we can't the back-end shouldn't be
able to access the interface the
interface should be able to access the
back hand if that makes sense that the
back hand probably took them tennis here
the the backend
okay so the networking portion should
have nothing to do with the interface
but the interface should have a
networking portion if that makes sense
now because of that if we want to do
something like print something we might
have a bit of a problem so rather than
doing something as silly as this is what
we've done here what we're gonna do is
instead of basically deciphering this
little message here we're gonna do we're
basically gonna do things a bit
differently rather than just kind of
have this we have say we have the string
we're save and we do return the message
yet rather than then calling all this
and actually as you can see doing all of
it here which is what we did let's not
put this here at all let's go back into
client window and we have this we don't
actually so let's make it in in client
here let's make a um I don't know if we
don't though we have to actually I made
that apparently not so how did hang on a
minute
this is something doesn't make sense
here open connection receives and okay
okay doesn't matter so we'll make a
public void listen okay and listen will
be basically run as a as a little kind
of recurring thing in a while loop in a
minute yeah but what listen will do is
it will actually go ahead and go client
don't receive on its own thread of
course otherwise we'll be here forever
so we'll make a new thread here and
we'll go client don't receive oh well
not really
so listen listen will permanently I
guess the only job listen will ever do
is just listen for any kind of thing so
I'll call this receive or listen equals
new thread and then we'll go ahead
scroll up here and go ahead and go
private thread listen just so we can
reference the thread properly if we need
to in the future that's why I'm creating
it as a zone object so while it true
alright and we can share this to a while
running later I don't think there's a
running others not okay
that's yeah okay it does matter well I
don't know I thought I did this stuff
maybe I'm imagining it's because of this
heat so while running
oops what's complaining about now oh hi
I'm Matt oh yeah okay and I wanted him
to do this way oh well we could but do
we want to yeah okay we'll do it this
way so we'll have to make one of these
things up all right there we go
so um while running we'll go ahead and
receive stuff and this will be of course
string it message equals client receive
and this is the message so now we can
paste it out if message starts with a
blah blah we can set the ID to something
we can do whatever we like which is the
awesome thing so we'll go ahead and say
we have this client so client dot client
dot asset ID okay equal to that then
we'll make that method here in a minute
so I'll just go ahead and hover the
mouse here and go create a method in
type client so set ID what that will do
is set this dot ID equal to ID and I'll
change that a capital just so it looks
better
all right and then uh we should be good
okay and then what we'll do as well as
we'll print out
we could simply of course print out you
know this is your ID welcome but that
might be a bit for the user that might
be like what's going on it's printing
ideas and stuff for me so all we might
do instead is do something like
successfully connected to server ok and
then just for good measure just for the
sake of what I'll do here quickly though
is also make a public avoid get ID which
will return ID just for the sake of this
tutorial I'm actually going to print out
the ID just so you guys can see that it
works but I'll probably be removing that
what's up with this public ok changes to
public and to get ID I'm public void
since it isn't aid returning something
which is initiative so connect with
connect to the server
i D and then plus client dot get idea
okay
simple as that now we need to make a run
method here so we'll make one actually
called run BAM by run yeah so we'll make
it yet okay
and we'll implement runnable here so it
implements whoops implements implements
writable I'm gonna pretend I know
English here and of course to make that
all happy n' and warm inside we need to
actually make a run method so while
running essentially what we want to do
here and this is where we're adding kind
of the dynamic almost portion to our
server we're saying that we're actively
going to listen for things so um we need
to listen oh sorry this actually doesn't
have to be while running that would be
disastrous if we made it that will
simply listen okay and then that will of
that of course has its own thread and
they'll be able to do its own stuff so
we're in the water about that but
essentially what should happen here is
what we actually we need to do two
things right you know when we do create
the window we've sent this whatever we
want to go ahead and say run which is
our wrong thing don't start
but before we do that we need to run
equals new thread this we'll call it the
running thread all right and then this
one over here which is our let's see our
listened thread will actually call it
the listened thread okay and the reason
we're actually naming these is because
when debugging comes into play if
something's wrong we can easily debug
what thread is wrong whether then we can
say okay that's the lesson thread that's
actually listening for any data okay so
what should happen now is we should be
sending a little something called an
attempt in connection method we do send
of course our name here so in in server
let's just verify that when server
receives that name thing it actually
knows what to do with it
so um if string starts would see here
right because this is processing
everything here if string starts with C
it assigns unique identifier but it
doesn't actually send anything back
the client it adds the client it printed
to send anything back so what we need to
do is send back to that client so I
think we can just run the send method
here yes we can we can send the the the
data here I guess being something along
the lines of well actually we know
exactly what we need to send let's make
a string of it first so string I guess
string ID equals so we've got this
connection little prefix here and then
we've got the ID that we've assigned to
the client which is just this we could
use the get ID method to be well
actually no that isn't that like that I
would got the ID method here and oh I
just realized I've named it the same
thing make books capitalize it ID okay
and then we'll go ahead and say ID dot
get bytes okay and then the address of
course will be the clients address which
over here I think is packages packet dot
get address and the ID or vulnerability
the port is get well packet dot get port
okay and that last you relied back to
the client simple as that and that's it
right that's how we verify connection so
what so what should happen here before I
run this and I haven't tested this yet
of course you guys haven't seen me do
that no I just screw something up didn't
I yeah I did
so listen dot start because I saw the I
saw the little yellow underlined here
and I was like whoops didn't ever
actually stop that okay so we've started
this method so what should happen here
is we should um we should attempt a
connection we should send this over a
pack of being like yo what's up my name
is Yan I'm connecting to your server
[ __ ] and then we should get a response
like sweet man welcome to my welcome to
my McRib here's your identifier yeah so
that's what should happen I've obviously
simplified for you guys now um so we're
gonna go ahead and open server let's
just save this server main which is our
actual running morning rule server and
no no no I'm opening the wrong crap
why is there a 7 main thing in the Sun
come on again ok you don't screw this
it's in the left side I'll open it
sorry um we'll go ahead and run that
which starts in use over here I'll just
move this up so you guys can see our
place that's a new server and a 192 as
you guys can see we also got to go ahead
and to login and open that and we will
type yarn here localhost 8 1 9 2 hit
login and what we should see here is oh
look at that
so we don't actually receive anything
from the user gets this is good so what
happens here is we 127.0.0.1 we receive
the connection it seems like everything
works here but unfortunately you can see
that over here in the chat thing nothing
actually prints okay so what we should
be saying here is the clients what we
should be seeing here is the ID but that
doesn't happen ok so let's go ahead and
debug that now this is where the fun
part of this tutorial begins and because
I've done this live I could have done
I'm gonna mess everything up but let's
go I get let's go ahead into okay so we
set the ID to that and then we get the
ID so it should be printing matter
regardless of what the idea is ID is
there's not a problem with the ID at all
client don't receive if we go back into
that we reset so socket receive we
actually do receive something here
probably and then we get the packet data
and when we turn it so guess that that
should be valid right if we actually go
into oh okay this is what happens
whenever set running equal to true so
make sure that you set running equal to
true here that's what I've forgotten so
let's go ahead and launch that again um
in fact you don't we shouldn't do it
that way which is that running an eagle
true before when we make the thread
because if we sell it threatened running
is false you know what yeah there might
be a bit of if we we should set or
anything first otherwise they might be
them it's possible there might be a bit
of overlap and we might lose it lose a
paddle too well so we'll go ahead and
enter serving-man we'll start that beast
up again I'll just try and drag this up
desperately here okay cool and also go
into login launch that yon localhost
a19 to login
okay and we crashed wonderful this is
good so now we've actually now actually
know what's wrong and guessed so
integer.parseint I did not work so
clearly I've screwed something up in
their message like a so what happens
number format exception so it's not a
number essentially why would that have
happened probably 0 1 2 then thousand 3
so 0 1 2 3 that looks like a number to
me Oh weird
yeah okay
so this is the number we're trying to
get it's telling us that's wrong so
either we've screwed something out with
indexes or something is just wrong
let's go ahead and print out what that
actually gives us I might have just
screwed something up so we'll grab this
and baby here copy it and then we'll
just print it out to the normal console
here alright and we'll launch the thing
again here so a local host I have one
mine too alright dry this up login ok 9
7 so that's perfectly normal what's
wrong with you huh is there a space at
the end of that no oh yeah it does seem
like that that does seem like a space to
me that's kind of weird actually
mm-hmm do we send it we can't send it
with the space though can we let's try
minus one and I guess we'll see what
happens so let's go ahead and add a
minus 1 into here because that's quite
it's quite odd it's giving us it's
telling us that it's not a number but it
is which is quite bizarre so we've
probably got a space let me in there huh
we're crushing it huh
so we're getting a number format
exception over here
that's um
so message
dotsub string you know what i okay you
don't screw that let's do it a different
way and I know this is kind of I might
work that out later and post it but the
other way that I liked it personally I
don't do it with the substring thing
what I usually do is I just say message
dot split and then I use it rejects
which is basically just going to be that
and then I take the the first value so
inaudible the second one in this case it
starts with zero but the second one okay
and that should give us the right things
we'll try that out and see what happens
because it looks like a number to me so
that's just kind of a bit weird and
that's crushed again huh is there is
this seriously like a space at the end
of that why is that crashing so you guys
get to witness some pretty sick
debugging here as you can tell that
thing so the length should be 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 the length of the things should be 7
that's all we know okay so 7 should be
the length that's less good message dot
a length just print that out so this
should be equal to 7 if it's not we know
that there's a space at the end of that
hit login
whoa 1024 oh yes this is perfect this
leads us on to our next tutorial
perfectly okay I bet you guys didn't
expect that that was all planned this
leads up into our next episode perfectly
so the length as you can see the string
is 1024 why is that well nobody knows
what we'll find out next episode so
thank you guys for watching we'll leave
a like if you enjoyed it I'll see you
guys next time goodbye
you